just programming right now A 2022 Ram
diesel one ton in the past we haven't
been able to program these things so we
just programmed in two keys we're using
the autel
im508 we're connecting through into the
OBD2 and the star connector right from
there we've had nothing but trouble
trying to get these things programmed
this is great we're using Tom tussing's
Cable and the uh or determinator Tom
thank you Tom this thing works
brilliantly it's absolutely fantastic so
able to program now
one ton Dodges so they should be able to
do like 2020 right up to 2023 but this
is our first attempt that was so easy
and uh absolutely love it
so it's Tom tussing's cable with the
autel
im508 and we programmed in a couple Keys
fobs for 20.
22 Ram three quart one ton diesel and it
worked flawlessly
foreign